après tout ce temps où on est restées
confinées à la maison c'est vrai que
c'est sympa de pouvoir revenir sur le
site cas quand même super sympa et en
plus on a beau temps donc c'est plutôt
une belle chose
le public est heureux mais clairsemée
pour ce premier concours d'obstacles de
saône et loire avec du public les
organisateurs ont volontairement étaler
les épreuves sur l'ensemble de la
journée pour éviter les rassemblements
trop important mais pour les cavaliers
la passion est à nouveau rendez-vous
tout le monde déjà à bord a été surpris
on s'y attendait pas tout est reparti là
est tout le monde a envie
puisque nous on avait quand même il ya
bien sûr et la compétition mais il ya
aussi le côté loisir les gens ont envie
de ressortir ils ont envie de bouger
je pense aussi que nos shows sont
longtemps parce qu'elles sont sorties de
cette routine quand même c'était un peu
différent pour les shows de compétition
vise avait besoin
une renaissance pour le saut d'obstacles
mais la filière a malgré tout souffert
économiquement de ces trois mois et demi
d'interruption en termes de manque à
gagner
nous c'est quasiment 25% du chiffre
d'affaires qu'on va laisser en route à
la fin de l'année et encore on a pu
bénéficier de beaucoup de dates de
concours hippiques qui ont été reportés
voilà c'est plutôt du côté du centre
équestre et du haras national où là on
sait que ce qui a été perdu et on le
retrouvera pas cette année le secteur
équin est important bourgogne la région
compte plus de vingt mille licenciés et
génère plus de 200 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires chaque année